le 15 août dernier les etats-unis
subissait un véritable camouflet au
conseil de sécurité des nations unies
seule la république dominicaine avait
alors soutenu les américains au sujet de
l'embargo sur les ventes d'armes en iran
depuis son conflit ouvert avec téhéran
donald trump a dégainé une nouvelle arme
baptisé snap bac aujourd'hui j'ai
demandé au secrétaire d'état mike p o de
notifier au conseil de sécurité de l'onu
que les états unis entendent rétablir
pratiquement toutes les sanctions des
nations unies contre l'iran jusque là
suspendu c'est un snack bac
objectif pour le président américain
imposé au conseil de sécurité des
nations unies le rétablissement de
toutes les sanctions internationales
contre l'iran
un mécanisme juridique controversé qui
pourrait définitivement anéantir
l'accord de vienne
cet accord souvenez-vous a été trouvé en
juillet 2015 après douze années de rudes
négociations entre l'iran les états unis
et cinq autres grandes puissances dont
la france la russie ou encore
l'allemagne long d'une centaine de pages
de texte prévoit notamment de limiter
l'enrichissement d'uranium de l'iran
limiter la production de plutonium
renforcer les inspections maintenir
l'embargo sur les armes ou encore levé
les sanctions contre téhéran
mais voilà c'était sans compter
l'arrivée à la maison blanche d'un
maniaque de l'immobilier qui n'a jamais
caché son mépris pour le travail de son
prédécesseur et son opposition à cet
accord sa première attaque intervient en
octobre 2017 estimant unilatéralement
que l'iran ne respecte pas l'accord
international sur son programme
nucléaire
il annonce donc une politique plus ferme
à l'égard de la république islamique
des menaces mises à exécution le 8 mai
2018 avec le retrait unilatéral des
états unis de l'accord de vienne un coup
de massue pour la diplomatie
internationale qui a alors dénoncé un
retour en arrière incompréhensible il ya
quelques jours téhéran présenter ces
deux nouveaux missiles de croisière
d'une portée respective demi
1400 kilomètres comme une réponse à
cette démonstration de force en pleine
campagne présidentielle
les etats unis ont annoncé mercredi
qu'il comptait avoir recours aux sna bac
comprenait au retour en arrière ce
mécanisme permet aux américains a dû
user de leur participation initiale à
l'accord sur le nucléaire iranien de
2015 pour obtenir une ére imposition
automatique de toutes les sanctions
préexistantes
bien que donald trump est décidé de
quitter cet accord en 2018
cette démarche reste possible du fait de
la résolution 2231 de l'accord de vienne
est sa clause de pays participants le
gouvernement américain entend donc
invoquer son statut de pays participants
qui lui garantit les mêmes droits que
les autres pays signataires
même en cas de sortie de l'accord les
états participants ont donc la
possibilité de dénoncer unilatéralement
je cite un non-respect notable des
engagements de la part d'un autre
signataire une procédure inédite qui au
terme de trente jours peut aboutir au
rétablissement du fameux sna back des
sanctions internationales contre téhéran
et ce sans possibilité pour les autres
signataires d'opposer leur veto cette
remise en cause au moins partielle de
l'un des acquis emblématique de l'ère
obama pourrait ouvrir une période de
grande incertitude
donald trump est bien décidé à aller au
bout de son projet quitte à isoler
davantage son pays moscou pékin à paris
londres et berlin n'ont pas hésité à
mettre en garde de washington contre un
retour en arrière qui pourrait avoir de
lourdes conséquences sur la diplomatie
internationale et la stabilité de la
région